firstly we've been helped very much by
the Nobel Committee because they really
helped to define a certain part of work
and I would say that the work that we
did was to develop models for the big
molecules in chemistry and biology that
would enable one to do calculations on
these models now one needs to remember
that computers were really really slow
back then something like a hundred
million times slower than today and
basically the key thing was was to
simplify things and like Einstein once
said something which was least is
executed is agnolotti
wikiquote said it wasn't really him and
that wasn't that you should make
everything as simple as you can but no
simpler so we had to make things as
simple as we could sort of the computer
could do the calculation but not so
simple that the results would be
meaningless
and we were lucky I think we got the
right level of simplicity we were then
able to put it into the computer and do
calculations on large molecules
simulations it's a bit like simulating
the weather which I guess in Sweden
doesn't work very well but in some
countries like California it really
works well because tomorrow will be like
today will be like yesterday and so on
but in calculations you can do the same
thing for a lot of biological molecules
and then you can sort of calculate the
data in between experiments so it
becomes a tool that can be used with
experiments and I think it's it's I
think there's gonna be many many things
in the future where computers are going
to be so important